on today's show we're going to be
talking about a hard topic so
you might want to screen this one first
be aware of any little ears that might
be in the room
we're going to be talking with the young
woman who calls in dealing with the
aftermath of an abortion
she thinks she did the right thing and
she's really struggling with grief and
so we're going to weigh
deep into the waters and i want you to
join us on this hard but beautiful call
we're also going to be talking about
seasonal affective disorder when we talk
about what it is
what it's not and what you can do with
dealing with
the gray winter months stay tuned
[Music]
hey what up what up i'm john and this is
the dr john dolone show where we are
taking your calls
about your life your dilemmas
your next wobbly crooked steps i want to
help you rethink
re-examine and re-imagine your life
paint a new picture and then go get it
and then go get it we're going to talk
about how to talk about yourself how to
talk about your
kids how to talk with your kids school
teachers
how to talk to your friends who have cat
families or dog families we're going to
talk about love
and loss and family issues we're we can
talk about infidelity finding love again
and we may talk about your friend who
continues
nine months in to can use the word
unprecedented
we've got it everybody we've got it it's
unprecedented from here on out
thank you for the heads up so whatever's
going on in your heart your home your
head
i'm here to stand with you and walk with
you give me a call at
1-844-693-3291-184-693-3291
leave a message leave your name and
number at the tone
tell us what's going on and kelly will
reach out and
set up a time for us to talk or
if you're old school like me and you
just want to write a letter
email me at askajohn ramseysolutions.com
that's super not old school that's if
you're old school in a new era you've
been
shoved into the 21st century and you
have to write letters with keyboards and
the emails and the internets email me at
ask john
ramseysolutions.com and let me know
what's going on
leave your name your number and we will
get in touch with you people are
emailing and calling from all over the
world
it's exciting it's heartbreaking it's
uplifting
and i'm just so thankful that
everybody's joining us for this ride
let's uh let's go straight to the phones
here let's go to alex in san antonio
good morning alex how are we doing good
morning john i'm doing
awesome how about yourself same same
so how can i help this morning um okay
so in uh late april of this year
i found out i was pregnant um
i was about three to five weeks so it
was really early on
and i made the best decision for me and
i went through with an abortion
okay um it's october and i'm still
finding myself falling into
these moments of just utter guilt
anger and sometimes a lot of shame and
my question is
how can i move forward and hopefully
forgive myself and you know maybe turn
this into a better experience than i'm
experiencing now
number one thanks for calling thanks for
your trust
and for giving me a shout so before i
answer you i just want to pause here
for everybody across the world who's
listening
and immediately alex when you said this
the the listener divided into one of two
camps
which is i can't believe this is even a
big deal
or i can't believe this happened right
and you know
this yeah and so what i'm not going to
do for you
or um particularly for listeners who
this is a third real topic right for
everybody
is i'm not going to beat you up
and i'm not going to give you my
insights and thoughts
what i'm going to do is sit with you in
this moment
and we're going to talk through this
together and so for those who are
listening who are hoping i'm going to
start banging a gong on either side of
this conversation i'm not going to
i'm going to sit with my new friend alex
here and we're going to wade into
the messiness and the heartbreak and
their reality and then try to
come up with a path moving forward and
so alex
thanks for letting me have a little
aside there so walk me through
when you find out you're pregnant detail
me
whose dad what role did he play in this
how did that conversation go
um so i have been with my boyfriend at
that point for a little
under a year i'm still with him
he's a wonderful person for me
you know he was very scared worried and
at the time he didn't have a job
he had actually been employed for a
little bit for quite some time for a few
months actually
um and he was supportive
of whatever decision we wanted to do but
i definitely felt
he didn't want to go through with it
which was understandable with his
circumstance and his situation
he didn't want to go through with having
the baby yeah
i mean again he was supportive of
whatever i wanted to do but
it was he was definitely more adamant
that we should consider going through
with abortion
okay so you have this um
you have this procedure um walk me up
the week leading up to it what's in your
heart and mind and then walk me
through what's in your heart and mind
the week after
going towards that day
it felt easier and then the night before
i just break down for hours i don't even
want to sleep because
i don't want the day to come i don't
want that moment to come
since it was coveted time i couldn't
bring anybody with me to support me
my mom drove me there but um
you know she couldn't be there to hold
my hand or anything like that
um and and then afterwards
i don't know i didn't cry afterwards
like i thought i was or
had i did the night before i just was
really sad and empty is what it felt
like i didn't want to cry i didn't want
to
do anything and my birthday was that
same week and i didn't want to celebrate
it
i didn't want to do anything um it was
hard
to be happy for that week and gradually
it started to get easier
but that week before seemed easy then it
got hard the day
and the night of and then just felt kind
of
empty the day after and the week after
really
well thank you for sharing that so when
you talk about your um
this was the right thing for you to do
when you when someone makes a statement
like that
that generally is them verbalizing
outwardly
a a um
leaning up against an internal value
that may be a little bit different
right so i'm thinking of a situation
that's totally unrelated here so
if this is a bad analogy it's off the
top of my head so i'm just kind of
kind of speaking off out of my heart
hearing off off the cuff
but if i'm a guy who believes in being
kind to everybody
and then i see somebody at a grocery
store and they
mouth off to the um
they say something just insanely
obscenely
ugly to the woman who has taken our
money
who's working the cash register and i
just
blast that dude i hit him as hard as i
can and he falls down
my first thought is going to be or my
first statement might be in that
situation
i just had to do it right it was it was
the right thing to do in that moment i'm
normally
this way but in that moment i just right
and so i begin this cycle of
justification i begin
talking to myself in a way that's going
to make what i just did okay
but at the end of the day it violated an
internal value and so what i'm getting
we're trying to get it with you is
did this violate your internal value
or is this have you always been
pro-choice have you always been it's
situational
or is this something you never thought
of or have you been
staunchly pro-life your whole life and
then all of a sudden you found yourself
pregnant and you found yourself in a
situation that
you felt like this was the best move for
you give me a sense of your values
before this
sure um i think i've always been a
pro-choice person when it comes to
in general every single woman in the
world
definitely has her own choice it's her
body i just always kind of
assumed that my position that if i ever
came to that decision
i wasn't gonna go i was i was gonna go
ahead and
i guess i was kind of pro-life for
myself for you i don't know if that
yeah totally we and we all have theories
and we all have
uh generalizations but then we all have
to look at the mirror right so that's
different for everybody
so you're several months removed now
you feel good that you did the
you you did the right thing that was for
you it did violate your internal code or
maybe not internal code but it violated
this
it's different than you thought you were
going to be right and you'd always
thought man if that ever happened to me
i wouldn't do that i would do x
and you ended up making the decision why
and now you find yourself several months
later we're in
on top of this and i just want to
contextualize it the world's literally
on fire
right it's um an absolute mess and so
you have trauma on top of trauma on top
of stress
and on top of an election on top of on
top of right
so you are sitting on a pile of trauma
collective trauma
and then you are wrestling with us walk
me through
what's in your heart right now
um in my heart right now um
it just there's just moments in time
uh that trigger me it's not a definitely
every day that i think about it or i try
not to at least but
there's just moments that you know i see
post on
social media and it's people with little
little babies who you know they they're
young like me
and you know i kind of just think that
maybe that wasn't a planned situation
but look how happy they are
and it just kind of triggers me or
i just hear like success stories or i
hear like
stories of other people going through a
miscarriage or even an abortion and it
just
it just makes me feel like i lost
something and i try to tell myself i
didn't
as much as i i guess i try to i don't
know i just i try not to tell myself it
was
it was not too much at the time you were
so early and
i don't know i mean sometimes i'm happy
you know and i know that i i try not to
say i made the right decision i try to
say i made the best decision with the
whole
with everything that was going on with
kovid my student loans financially my
emotional
my emotional situation at the time um
but it's just really little moments
throughout the week that
just hits me really hard i cry for 15
minutes and then
just try to move on are you and your
boyfriend talk about it
do y'all talk about it ever um we do
i don't bring it up to him for every
single time that i
get upset about it um and recently he
said he's been thinking about it
a lot more than usual and he's been kind
of sad about it too
so we do share that pain and we do talk
a little bit
but i don't tell them about every single
time because sometimes it's just on the
right home from
a friend's house or it's going to the
grocery store
and it's just little moments so what
you're describing
is a you just painted a beautiful
picture
of grief and
that's when intrusive thoughts is the
nerd term form but was when thoughts and
pictures pop into your head
of what could have been what wasn't um
and then you begin to backfill that
either your body responds with sadness
or your body responds with
arguments or your body responds with
this is done it's got a period at the
end of the sentence and now we've got to
move on right and
and then all of a sudden other voices
right so you talk about social media and
your friends and your boyfriend's
sadness
um those things start to to speak into
this as well
and one last thing before we can kind of
talk about what what healing will look
like do you have
people in your life you've talked to
about this you say your mom
actually took you and dropped you off is
she in support of this
do you have people around you that know
what happened
that um know you you
took this step and that are continuing
to love you and walk alongside you
i have three of the most or four of the
most beautiful best friends who
i did talk to and they definitely try to
make me feel better about
what i did you know and just kind of
support my decision
my mom was actually the one person who
was super excited
and i think that me a little bit because
i
didn't want her i wanted her to support
me but i didn't think she was going to
be happy about it and she was
but she was supportive when i told her
why and you know
she she was she was happy about being a
grandma or she was happy about your
decision to have an abortion
she was happy about the thought of being
a grandma gotcha okay
gotcha so
what do you think healing looks like for
you
i hope that i would eventually get the
courage to go see somebody to talk about
it
because i know that this one phone call
or talking to my boyfriend every once in
a while or friends is not always going
to make things better
um i just kind of hope that
one day i can look back on this and
realize that
making decisions is hard and having to
do what's best
for yourself and for others is hard but
i can take this experience and hopefully
when i
when i look back on it i just i feel
comfortable i feel
at ease with it um and then
hopefully when i do decide to move on
and have a child someday
i don't i get worried i might feel guilt
with it too
sure yeah and you don't want to feel
that
yeah absolutely so here's um
here's me being a straight talk with you
as i possibly can
and i'm going to walk through the woods
with you on this and i'm gonna end up
making everybody around us
uncomfortable i'm gonna make everyone
around us mad at me okay
and at this point i'm gonna do what a
good coach does what a good
person in somebody's corner does which
is walk alongside you
and have truthful hard conversations
okay so
the the there's there's myths that
abound on both sides
in in terms of the literature and the
science and here's what's going to
happen here's what's not going to happen
at the end of the day you've got to deal
with what's in your heart
right and you are going to both
be it at i won't say at ease but you're
going to be
you're going to have a period in the
sentence what has happened is what has
happened right
and you're also the the grief you are
feeling is
situational every person feels it
differently the data tells us
there is a wide swath of women who go
through with
an abortion procedure and they have
other kids
they've got a good partner with them and
they don't feel guilt or remorse or they
don't
regret the decision later on that's just
what the data tells us
there is also data that says a a small
number of folks
really really struggle with this and
then there's anecdotal evidence these
are just
folks students and adults that i've
walked with over the years
that are in your situation which feel
this they see a picture of a baby and
their stomach just drops
or you will hit a a a date that would be
the first birthday
or you will hold your first kid and it
will flood you with
oh this is what this would have been
right and everybody does that
differently
and everybody feels that grief or
doesn't feel that grief differently
so a couple of things that are real
important for you and that is to own
your grief
however you feel is okay
and if you don't feel bombarded with
grief
there's gonna be a group of people who
tell you you're evil and wrong
i might even believe that about you alex
but i'm not gonna say it out loud okay
and then there's going to be other folks
that if you wake up and you can't get
out of bed
because you're doubled over in grief you
are asking yourself what did i do what
did i do what did i do
there's going to be a group of people
saying are you kidding me get over it it
was just a procedure
and i might think that way alex and i'm
not going to tell you
the way you feel about this is yours to
own okay
as you move through this you said
something that i want you
to remember there's going to be moments
of discomfort there's going to be
moments of grief there's going to be
moments of flashbacks of memory
and they're just going to be
uncomfortable and that's going to be
part of the decision that you made
okay and fighting that trying to avoid
discomfort
trying to avoid sadness trying to avoid
grieving
is a fool's errand and it's going to
push you down
avenues that are going to be escapist
and a fancy word for escapist is
addiction
okay you're going to try to do things
that
avoid the discomfort and what i want to
suggest to you is you take those four
friends of yours
you take that mom who loves you you take
that boyfriend who is grieving with you
and you'll sit in the grief and you own
it
and you don't try to run from it you
don't let it overtake you and that's why
you have friends with you but you don't
run
from it at the end of the day what's
done is
done what has happened has happened and
the first person you're gonna have to
forgive is yourself
the first person you're gonna have to
make peace with is yourself and then
over time you're going to make meaning
with this
and so people make meaning out of these
sort of situations in
all different ways and what i'm going to
say now is going to sound like a
political statement
please for god almighty whose people are
listening to this don't go there because
i'm not i'm trying to the best i can to
avoid the politics of this
um we had a caller who called in the
other day and said that
they were in california their house
burned down in the fires and they lost
everything and they would move to
another house into another house and
those kept catching
fire and they were moving to safe places
and they were just stressed and freaked
out and they were dealing with
tragedy with grief and with loss and
what i recommended they do
is that they have a funeral for their
house and the things they lost
i often am telling people have a funeral
for your old marriage
have a funeral for your old relationship
and so
i would recommend having some sort of
grief
ceremony some sort of this happened this
is done
and there's a period at the end of this
we want to acknowledge that it hurts
we it may have been the best situ best
thing you felt it was the best thing for
you at the time
but it still hurts and it's still
popping up
and what a ceremony does for us is it
gives us a touchstone for how to move
forward
okay and not everybody needs to do a big
ceremony or a small one
but having some sort of touchstone
you've got to have other people when you
do this alex
but it's going to put a peer to thin of
that sentence for you and then you're
going to have to go about
healing forgiving yourself being in
community doing the things that you know
keep you well
and really not being afraid of
conversations with your
boyfriend too hiding grief comparing
grief with each other
is a is a surefire way to destroy a
relationship from the inside out
and he may grieve harder than you or
less than you and you may have seasons
where this is overwhelming and not a big
deal at all and it will just roll like a
roller coaster
and you guys have to provide space for
one another to be open
and then as you mentioned if you
continue to have this weigh on you
in ways that make you feel uncomfortable
and i've sat with folks who tell me that
this comes back and grabs them by the
throat
they feel like it is months behind him
years behind him and all of a sudden
it comes back and it's paralyzing the
guilt and the frustration is
overwhelming
you gotta see somebody okay and i want
to applaud your step
your courageous step for calling me but
you're gonna have to get a professional
to walk with you
especially if this morphs from grief
into
high guilt and shame and trauma then
you've got to have somebody that walks
alongside you
and again i've talked to other folks who
have been relatively dismissive
yeah it happened i kind of wish i hadn't
done that but it did and so i'm moving
all my life
everybody deals with this differently
and
at the end of the day you've got to have
people around you and you gotta forgive
yourself and you gotta go make
tomorrow the best it can be
you're right john i i really appreciate
you saying that i
it's just taking that first step i think
has been the scariest part this is
first time i've ever spoken to now i
guess a
party outside of my life and it feels
better
well i want to thank you for your trust
alex and um
if you if you hear anything if you hear
nothing else
you gotta have people around you even
people who hold you accountable even
people who look in the eye and say
i think what you did was dumb i think
that was a mistake but we're here now
right and um there's a difference
between judgmental friends and friends
who hold you accountable
and then there's friends who are just
going to walk alongside and say you're
allowed to sit down and just say this
sucks and we're going to cry with you
real hard and then we're going to make
sure you eat and we're going to make
sure you're sleeping and we're going to
make sure you're going to work
and we're going to walk alongside you as
you heal from grief and
again the second thing is you got to own
your feelings okay
and they're going to come in waves and
there's going to be moments when you
feel overwhelmed there's going to be
moments and i'm just basing this off
what you've told me right
and there's going to be moments when
your head's held high and you're just
walking through life
and if this pops up in three years in
five years if all of a sudden
you're at a first grade graduation and
you just get overcome
let that come and have a group of people
that you can call
and be with right grief is has a as a
weird way of just showing up in
different places
and then make sure you don't compare
grief with your
boyfriend don't let social media
tell you the right quote unquote right
way you're supposed to respond to this
on any side of this this debate and
again thanks for the call i want to
again i want to back up and and
remind everybody there are political
issues and abortion is one of those
things that
is a third real topic people feel
deep deep in their bones deep in their
bones
and i want to honor everybody who's got
their opinions
everybody who feels deeply powerful
about the right thing to do in these
situations and the wrong thing to do in
these situations
i honor you good for you have hard
core convictions we live in a world that
has gotten soft with convictions and
everyone's gotten mushy
good for you but
sitting with somebody in the pain the
aftermath of a decision that you
disagree with
is not the time to beat people over the
head
with your beliefs it is not the time to
drown somebody in what they did wrong
it's time to put your thoughts and your
opinions
and your beliefs in a on the ground
and you sit with them at the well and
you offer them a cup of water
and you say i see you and i love you and
this sucks and i'm sorry
and then you take them by the hand and
then you all start walking together
that's how you help people who are
hurting that's how you walk alongside
someone who's struggling
and these things that are there are
theories and
issues they involve real people with
real pain
and real regret and real vulnerability
and real
drama and real wasn't that big of a deal
it's all of it and so when you're loving
people who are hurting
love first judge later okay
thank you so much alex for the call um
that call helped a bunch of people it's
gonna get everybody in trouble
but i'm gracious for your bravery there
right
so let's go to a quick email real quick
um we'll just do a palette cleanser here
patrick writes what are your thoughts on
paying for therapy and counseling while
still in debt
so most of you know my boss is dave
ramsey with the dave ramsey organization
he is the get out of debt
king he gives people a tools
to become free financially and as he's
found over the last 25-30 years
that taking baby steps together
relationally helps heal marriages
helps heal communities but at the end of
the day it's about not being in debt
it's not being
slave to an owners when you owe money to
somebody
you have to keep doing what they want
you to do which is paying them
and you often end up in jobs you don't
like you end up in situations you don't
like because
you are in debt the borrower is slave to
the lender
and patrick asks what are my thoughts on
paying for therapy or counseling while
you're still in debt this is a
a broad question and here's why or it's
a telling question
we still think of therapy we still think
of counseling like we do
back massages like it's nice
if you can afford it it's a cool thing
to do to feel better
and i want to reframe therapy i want to
reframe
counseling as not a thing
that you know it's nice to do do it once
a month
if you need counseling it is a medical
condition think of it that way think of
it as would you
if you were really sick with covid
you're really sick with the flu
would you say well i'm in baby step two
for you dave ramsey folks i still have
some money i still have some student
loans so i'm not gonna go to the doctor
this month i broke my foot
i'm not gonna go get a cast because i
still owe
no you're gonna budget for it you're
gonna make it a priority
and you're going to go see somebody and
get the help you need
if you are still in debt and you need to
go to counseling
figure out a way to go to counseling
there are community outreach programs
i did my practicum part of my practicum
i did
at a family counseling service which was
is a sliding scale for
for marginalized community members who
have no money
they've got very little money they've
got low income
and it was a group of interns and
professionals who worked with this
group for very little to know the cost
it's important for folks going to
counseling to have some skin in the game
and so paying something is important
but it wasn't this an hour like some
some care is i also
had students that went to community
counseling centers i also
have a lot of colleagues and friends who
did practicums as graduate students so
if you live in a community
that has a college or university with
graduate students there
they will often do their practicum and
internship for free or for
very low wages that's a great place to
go see somebody and if they're not
good you don't like that they think
they're a good counselor go see somebody
else but all to say is there are options
and if it comes down to budgeting for it
budget for it
that may mean you can't go out to eat
twice and you got to cancel netflix
good good if you don't have that stuff
you'll eat a little healthier and you'll
go for walks and you'll go
kick the soccer ball with your neighbor
with your kid instead of just vegging
out in front of the tv
cut the things out of your life that you
need to cut cut the extraneous stuff
and figure out how to pay for counseling
but should you pay for counseling while
you're still in debt
absolutely budget for it and make it
happen
so excellent question patrick stop
thinking of counseling everybody
as a a back massage or a mani-pedi
and start thinking it as a cornerstone
of your
physical spiritual emotional and
psychological health if you need to go
to counseling
if you need to do it okay and i don't
think you should be in counseling
forever by the way
you should not go and go and go i've had
the same counselor for 14 years
that's a whole other issue that's a
whole other show all right so let's go
to the phones let's go to jay in dayton
ohio jay what's up brother how we doing
what's up brother thank you so much for
all you're doing i love the show
man i am grateful for you number one
thanks for letting me know that
um sometimes i just talk to folks on the
radio and then james and kelly put this
on the internet and i really don't
understand how that works and so i
appreciate hearing from real people
thanks man
so how can i help you this morning all
right man so here's the deal i'm
sad or what i'm calling about a seasonal
effective disorder i come up against
this every year
yeah and kind of my question to you is a
two-part question first of all
why is it happening is there something i
need to kind of fix
or or review and then further
what can i do about some of the the
effects of seasonal affective disorder
so i'm calling for myself obviously and
also
extended family and friends that i know
suffer with this so
just kind of looking to get your insight
into any help would be appreciated
to kind of outline a scenario
calling from the northeast great lakes
region
it's october right now the leaves are
beautiful but
seasons come seasons go and we're about
to
enter winter that's right right now
we're losing we're losing light
it's getting cool it's getting
depressing winter's right around the
corner
and it seems like year in and year out
this is a four to five month cycle
so just kind of reaching out i want to
get a jump on this and
get your insight all right brother i
love it and
kelly tipped me off that we were gonna
have a discussion about
seasonal affective disorder um and so
number one i'm grateful for your call
number two
i've got a personal experience here so
as as i run my mouth too much and i've
tried to back off on this i got all of
your cards and letters from everybody
listening that i talk too much about
texas
i'm trying not to mention it so much but
when i moved here from texas i was about
30 or 45 minutes from the new mexico
border
and which is another time zone right
it's the other time zone
and then i moved to nashville which is
about 30 or 45 minutes from
i think it's the eastern time zone and
man
my first winter here i was completely
caught off guard
it was getting dark at 4 30 i found
myself
winding up for bed at 6 45 in the
evening it was pitch black outside
i was things weren't funny anymore my
food tasted bland it was
it caught me off guard and i called
somebody's who had moved from
you know the south from the the from
texas from arizona and who had moved
east who'd moved north and they were all
like oh brother that's what that is and
i'd heard about it i'd read about it i'd
never experienced it but it was like
somebody laid a blanket over me right
and it occurred to me about february or
march
that that was the longest i'd ever gone
in my life without sunlight
and that was the like since i was a
little since i was born i'd always lived
in a place with lots of sun and it was a
it made a major impact on me so i dug
into it a little bit
and i will walk through with you some of
the nerd things i do
the super nerds call them hacks i don't
like using that word but some things
that i do
is some of it brother may be
psychosomatic meaning i mean
my brain may be playing tricks on me
saying it helps and it really doesn't
but it's working for me
and as i'm gearing up for that season i
know ohio is similar to nashville it
just feels like they lay this
gray blanket of clouds over us right and
it just lays there and gets
lower and lower the weather's beautiful
the scenery is beautiful
this morning on the way to work there
were deer and turkey out just
eating it looked all beautiful but man
there's just got that blanket laying
over us right
so exactly um it is super real seasonal
defective
seasonal affective disorder affects
millions of people
every year some folks have mild form
some have
major depressive responses the further
we live for the from the equator the
more it it
leans on us right so they say more sad
right
and then you're gonna throw in this year
i'm just prepping for it
um this year we're gonna have i don't
know if you've heard i don't know if
they've talked about this in ohio but we
have an election coming up in a few days
and you guys have may have missed um the
coronavirus has been a thing for the
last
nine months right so we're on tragedy on
top of tragedy on top of tragedy right
and so it's gonna i'm expecting it to be
heavier this year
and so why do we feel it um
some say that it is the sunlight is the
is the number one thing we are vitamin d
creatures we've got to have vitamin d
we've got to have sunlight and it
regulates our melatonin release it
regulates our
wake and sleep cycles and when those
things get compressed
um our bodies just shut down they just
slow down it's winter right
the same as the as the grass turns brown
right the trees the leaves fall off the
trees they're not dead but they just go
dormant for a while and our bodies do
something very similar
um and so sunlight helps stimulate
melatonin it helps simulate vitamin d a
whole cascade
of chemical systems right and without
that stuff vitamin d boosts serotonin
all
i don't be a super nerd here but it all
has chemical responses
and also we stop going out we stop being
around other people
we stop um meeting we just go to bed
it's early
and it's dark and let's just call it
let's just watch a little more netflix
get under the covers a little further
um some have said we stopped being
intimate with our
with our partners we stop right right so
you back off sex you you start eating a
little bit worse you start sleeping a
little bit more
and that's just signals to your body to
depress
stuff right to lay low so here's a
couple of things that i do personally
actually i'll walk through the big ones
and then i'll tell you a couple of the
nerd things that i do
um here's some highly intentional stuff
we can do number one
and these aren't going to be shockers or
anything
but go outside and enjoy nature
even if it's freezing make yourself
bundle up and go outside as often as you
can
um i i
am a big believer and there's no bad
weather there's just wrong clothes
and so if it's freezing and it's snowing
and it's raining
me and my kids are playing outside and
we are running around being
silly and it may be so cold that we are
chitter chattering and
but we're going outside um we're going
to continue to
be connected with one another and we're
going to continue to go outside um
even if it's just 15 minutes 10 minutes
15 minutes go outside right the second
thing is
is i this is going to this is me being
vulnerable here with
with the you and the 17 listeners of
this podcast
i put um human connection on my calendar
i am a person who retreats by nature and
so i have to have intentional
conversations i have to intentionally
see
people it's going to be challenging in
the winter this year because i've been
able to
this summer and this fall we have a lot
of outdoor conversations we have people
over but we eat out on the front porch
in the backyard
i'm gonna have to be hyper intentional
in a season of covid
in a season of winter being with other
people
you gotta see your friends you gotta see
your friends you gotta see your friends
be hyper intentional even if you have to
schedule it um
make sure that you are still being
intimate make sure you are still holding
hands make sure as you start every
morning
if you've got a pet you've got a
you know a significant other in the bed
next to you hold their hand
hug that dog right touch your bare feet
to their bare feet make sure you're
getting skin to skin contact
and you're feeling somebody else's
heartbeat do everything you can in your
power to eat well
sleep a lot and exercise not too much
not too little but man once you
once i get the sugar rush of oc of
halloween usually i can hold on till
halloween jay
and then i get on a gummy candy binge
and i really don't recover until january
till new year's
i just lose it man and then my wife
stays inside and she starts baking and
she's an extraordinary cook now my son's
a
chef now and he's baking everything my
daughter and i just mainline sugar it
just goes down a rabbit hole so
it's making highly intentional choices
about what i'm eating
and then have things to to look forward
to
one of the things depression does to us
even seasonally is
it makes us our bodies feel like our
minds feel like this is going to be this
way forever
and so plan something for early march
plan something for when the when this
when the like a vacation get out of town
even a small camping trip
but put some things on the calendar that
we can look forward to now here's a
couple of
nerd things and i've hinted at this a
little bit
for the last decade i've lived up to my
eyeballs
in the research literature with the
outer banks of what i would call
woo-woo stuff and with just
basic just physiology and human anatomy
here's a couple of things that i double
down on now
in the winter months starting now is a
highly
regimented no questions asked i cannot
skip it and this is a personal
commitment
cannot skip a morning routine that
involves
meditation that involves silence that
involves my feet
on bare ground this is grounding that's
super woo but i think
i think the science supports it but it's
5 or 10 or 15 minutes with my feet on
bare ground
it is feeling the seasons and it is an
exercise program that
no matter what's coming um i'm going to
exercise even if i get halfway through
my pro
my workout that morning i'm going to do
something i also
am a big weimhoff guy w-i-m-h-o-f we'll
link to him in the show notes
he is all about cold thermogenesis
ice baths and these are not ice baths
like athletes take after a hard workout
this is ice baths as a way of regulating
your body
and i won't get into the science here
but i take i have a
tub that i bought from a a outdoor farm
supply store
and it's a metal tub that i fill with
water and sits outside in the winter
and it usually has ice in it floating in
it or it's frozen over
and i get in there from three to six to
ten minutes sometimes
every morning every morning sometimes in
the evening and it is unbearable and it
is brutal and it is beautiful
um and so it is called cold
thermogenesis wimhoff he's awesome
the last thing here i'll talk through
this for the podcast but i will
show it for the youtube um i don't get
paid for any of these things
thorne and keon those are the two
supplement companies that i trust
i overdo it probably on vitamin d k2
i've got it here this is what i take
regularly i take a lot of it
um the research on vitamin d and covid
the research on vitamin d
and seasonal defective disorder and
hormone regulation and
all the different biomechanical
mechanism bio mechanisms
vitamin d regulates a lot and so does k2
and so does magnesium so i take a lot of
that stuff
and here's one of my nerd gadgets that i
love it's called the human charger
by valky it's it's obnoxiously expensive
but you put it in your ears and it
actually
shines a bright light into your ear it's
an led light when i show friends and
family they roll their eyes and say that
money would have been better if you had
set it on fire
i love this thing i think it works i use
it every morning on the way to work
um it cycles through two or three it's
called the human charger you can look it
up on the internet we'll link to in the
show notes i love that thing too
but it's about bright lights and so when
you wake up in the morning
turning this bright of lights on as you
can i've heard the investments in the
the sad bulbs they call them are worth
it they're good
and so um being intentional about making
sure you're around a lot of bright light
the right kind of light
and letting your natural biorhythms
work even when the sun is down here's
one final thing
you've heard me say this on the podcast
often and i'll continue to say it
we try as if people for the last hundred
years
to power through nature we have tried to
hit the gas
and turbo charge and jet propulse our
way as though
nature didn't know what she was doing
we've tried to to
i mean i don't want to get into it here
we've tried to out
farm mother nature by just beating the
soil to death we've tried to
out um uh outgrow
animals beyond mother nature we've just
lost our minds we thought we won
and mother nature is proving as she
always does that she
knows what she's doing that she's in
control and there's an ebb and flow to
the world
one of the things we can do in the
winter months
is just slow down just slow down
and that's hard for us right but we have
to remember that up until about 60 years
ago you couldn't get apples in the
grocery store
in february because it was winter and
apples weren't growing
and we could not just get sunshine all
the time
and there was a natural pulse and a
natural rhythm to life and so i want to
encourage everybody
to take care of yourself do these things
right we got to keep showing up for work
i've got to keep showing up to the
podcast
i've got to keep doing the things i've
got to do to keep food on my table
and also listen to the rhythms of nature
listen to the rhythms of your body and
it's okay
to sleep a little bit more it's okay to
get a little more pensive it's okay to
write a little bit more in your journal
or to add five or six things to your
gratitude journal every morning
it's okay to read a little bit more it's
okay to slow down and so i don't want us
to spend so much energy
fighting the natural systems but at the
same time there are some cool things we
can do to
lift this up all right um let's see here
i want
i want to shout out i got a shout out
here from sabrina
sabrina siegers she writes that she
heard
one of my shows from a few days ago a
few weeks ago and
she instantly thought of her husband now
what's
awesome is she didn't leave his her she
didn't leave her husband's name
so sabrina siegers if you are out there
i got your note
he has been he has been by your side you
all have been uh married for four years
you've been struggling with infertility
for three of those four years and you've
had mental health challenges you've been
struggling
and all that through that oh there it is
there it is your husband josh
has been your rock none of this was in
the picture when y'all got married
and he continues to hold you he
continues to walk alongside you
his number one dream has been to be a
dad and he's surrounded by all of his
friends getting that yet he has turned
our trial around this is what she writes
to be the best uncle to your family and
friends they love him and he continues
to show up in their lives
he lives a quiet life and doesn't get
enough credit
all men could learn from him how to live
deeply in these hard seasons and how to
care for their wife and their emotions
not trying to fix them
but just being with them our anniversary
is october 30th and i would love for a
shout out for all he has done
josh siegers whose wife is sabrina she's
calling you out brother
thank you for being a guy who just loves
his wife
and is doing the best he can to sit with
her during hard seasons
what a stud dude what a stud all right
so as we wrap
up today's show man i
i'm just gonna say the greatest song of
all time by one of the greatest bands of
all time
off the greatest album of all time
this song is so good i have no idea what
it even means
i don't know what it means i just know
it's the greatest of all time this is
the best song
hundred percent about a calendar right
it's the best about a calendar
ah man the band has one word it's got
two words but one's an indefinite
article doesn't matter it's got one word
the album was one word
and the songs about a day of the week
the record
dropped in 1992 it was called poof
wish it was by the band the cure and the
song is
friday i'm in love
robert smith writes i don't care if
monday's blue
tuesday's gray and wednesday too
thursday
i don't care about you it's friday i'm
in love
monday you can fall apart tuesday
wednesday break my heart
thursday doesn't even start it's friday
i'm in love saturday wait
sunday always comes too late but friday
never hesitate it's friday i'm in love
and this is the dr john dalone show